this is just the beginning
- you welcome - now you see movie
sequels are impossible to predict some
become classics and some become the most
hated movies of all time so what makes a
sequel good and why do sequels have such
a hard time not sucking do the same
thing as last time everyone's happy
let's compare similar sequels to see
what works and what doesn't one of the
biggest obstacles with a great sequel is
that you have to do something new maybe
the first movie worked great but the
sequel can't be the same thing or it'll
suck the sequels that we all love mix it
up and surprise us the first Terminator
features Arnold Schwarzenegger as the
villain and he's such a terrifying
villain because he's not even human
he's a robotic monster whose only
objective is to kill Sarah Connor a lazy
unsurprising sequel would put us in the
same world with the Terminator trying to
kill again
but James Cameron surprises us and in a
spectacular twist Arnold is actually
sent to protect John Connor from another
more powerful terminator get down now
that's a great sequel and then there's
speed the first speed is about a cop who
tries to rescue civilians from a bus
rigged to explode if any of the
civilians try to get off or the bus
slows down its action-packed and
suspenseful from start to finish
the sequel speed 2 has the same general
idea but the bus is now a luxury cruise
ship the surprise is amazingly lame a
slow-moving cruise ship is way less
thrilling than the fast moving bus in
the first speed the surprise isn't a
surprise it's a letdown
sequels also need to build they need to
add something and what they add has to
be good 22 Jump Street has the same
general plot as 21 Jump Street the only
real difference between the two films is
that one takes place in high school and
the other in college but the second film
adds a whole gag about the movie itself
they constantly make references to how
doing the same thing over and over again
will not lead to the same result it's
always worse the second time around
they're making fun of the fact that
sequels never work they build on 21 Jump
Street by now making fun of themselves
it's clever original unique and
hilarious I can't believe the Koreans
bought the church back yeah I mean good
thing there was even bigger abandoned
Church directly across the street yeah
yes it is convenient The Hangover Part 2
tries to build on the original instead
of taking place in Las Vegas the sequel
is in the much more exotic Thailand
that's really the only addition to the
original there's nothing new here
there's no built
leave this happening again an inherent
problem with feature-length film is that
the amount of possible character
development is limited to the
hour-and-a-half length of the movie so
in a medium like television we can see
so many complex changes in a character
over the course of several seasons
whereas a movie can show maybe one or
two major changes but the sequel though
we have a chance to see characters we
love and the original grow even more I
think any sequel that doesn't take
advantage of this opportunity for more
character growth is a disappointment Toy
Story for example shows us a whole new
character arc for woody in the sequel in
the first film what he makes a
realization that getting the most
attention isn't what's important what
matters is that we're here for Andy when
he needs us and then in the sequel what
he has another realization that while
his time with Andy is temporary he would
rather spend his limited time making
Andy happy over being displayed in a
museum
you're right prospector I can't stop
Andy from growing up but I wouldn't miss
it for the world
through the sequel we get further
insight into Woody and his dedication to
end we learn more about what he's goals
his fears and his obstacles the sequel
added just as much depth to the main
character as the first film which in the
end is what turns sequels into classics
we can see this added depth to
characters and other great sequels like
The Godfather Part 2 with Michael
Corleone and the Dark Knight with Bruce
Wayne when we compare these sequels to
something like Cars 2 and The Hobbit
franchise we see another way movie
sequels can suck Cars 2 doesn't show any
change to the characters from the
original and even with almost eight
hours of screen time for The Hobbit
series we see hardly any character depth
in most of the ensemble cast I have to
commend the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for knowing how to make great sequels
you can tell from their consistent
continuity writing style crossovers and
brand marketing that Disney isn't making
sequels just for one-time cash grabs
Disney is attempting to make very
long-term profit by creating a lasting
franchise and brand and it seems to be
working their sequels surprise build and
add character depth think about the
Avengers we get loads of surprises when
our favorite superheroes fight it out
build on Plus from previous films and we
see tons of character depth by seeing
the conflict of interest between each
superhero I'm not saying Marvel movies
are the greatest movies of all time but
what I am saying is that Marvel knows
how to make sequels and that's saying a
lot
given the countless disappointments
we've seen in sequels
making a good sequel to a great original
is definitely a challenge but I think a
big problem with sequels is that a lot
of the time the studio doesn't really
care if a sequel is well reviewed with
the successful original as long as the
sequel is okay it's almost guaranteed to
make a profit for the studio remember
that despite all the hate towards
sequels like cars - The Hangover Part 2
and the Star Wars prequels they grossed
more than their original films sequels
create an interesting paradox in the
film industry to be successful a film
normally has to show something unique
like great special effects acting or
plot but a sequel can make a profit only
by having a recognizable name and
providing nothing unique so do Hollywood
a favor and stop going to sequels that
suck God willing we'll all meet again in
space boats - to search for more money
thanks for watching